[Music]
2022 will soon enter the history books
happy almost New Year everybody Welcome
to Entertainment Tonight yeah if you've
got big plans with your couch this
evening we've got you covered here's
everything you need to know starting
with the party in the city that never
sleeps
more than 1.2 billion people are
expected to tune in worldwide to watch
the ball drop tomorrow night and with no
coveted restrictions in place the
in-person crowd is expected to be the
biggest in years New York City officials
are estimating one million people will
pack into Times Square with just hours
to go check out this look behind the
scenes there are workers inspecting and
replacing some of the Waterford Crystal
triangles that cover the iconic sphere
but the ball drop won't be the only
drama to watch in the Big Apple I just
want you to know Anderson and I are
going to party harder than we have ever
[Applause]
do you understand me
yep we hear you loud and clear that's
Bravo's Andy Cohen who co-anchor CNN's
New Year's Eve coverage with his bestie
Anderson Cooper cheers
it's big news out there yes that our old
friend Chris Licht who used to be the
exec on this show who's now running CNN
says no drinking on New Year's Eve yeah
is that gonna hold is that gonna hold
Andy seemed to imply to Rolling Stone
that a no drinking on New Year's rule
didn't apply to him quote it's fun for
me because I'm a guest on CNN so I'm
like a visitor I can kind of torch the
place while I'm there and then head out
do a shot of tequila Andy's made
headlines with his alcohol-fueled rants
on CNN including this one last year Ryan
Seacrest group of news that are
performing behind us I just got doused
with confetti from the fake Journey
appearing on ABC if it's not Steve Perry
it doesn't count I mean really you get
it Ryan Seacrest meanwhile says he's all
for CNN limiting the alcohol quote I
don't Advocate drinking when one is on
the air it's probably a good idea to
scale back I think they had something to
say about my show at one point which was
I'm sure from the out alcohol because I
don't think they would say what they
said about our performers if they
weren't drinking we like to think we're
the only TV hosts on New Year's Eve who
are actually having fun let's move on
from New York to Nashville Rachel Smith
is there with country's biggest stars
getting ready to ring in the New Year
I've got to ask you New Year's
resolutions you know a lot of people
think about it what is it less drinking
I mean it starts with try to cuss a
little less okay that's a little less I
mean more efficient I mean try to just
feel a little healthier
all right so what are you performing the
last year you gave us knocking boots
what are you giving us this year we're
doing uh you gotta do country girls
country girls
you gotta ring the New Year in uh
shaking your country girl stuff and then
we do country on and then Hunting
Fishing loving every day Hunting Fishing
every day only E.T was with Luke Bryan
for his New Year's Eve rehearsal at his
Nashville bar that's also where I caught
up with Kane Brown
in between stops on his Global tour yeah
we just got back from Australia and then
we're about to go to Canada and then
Europe so we just keep growing the fan
base over there how does it feel small
tail Georgia Boy going global with his
music it feels amazing I never left
Georgia we couldn't afford anything
other than going to like Panama City
Beach so it's cool just to see the fans
over there and they singing everywhere
New Year's Eve live Nashville's big bash
which years on CBS will be hosted by
Jimmy Allen l king and yours truly are
you guys people that do New Year's
resolutions uh it's just more of a me
and my friends and family do a thing
where we just challenge each other to be
better than we were here before I'll
have everybody in my van and family
write down what I can improve on and
then light it on fire and never read it
to me that's gonna be my new tradition
thank you also performing Kelsea
ballerini bricks and Dunn and Sheryl
Crow
d
Nashville has become like the epicenter
of partying and I think people just
really love being here for the music so
you know to actually have a purpose in
all of it to like say we're starting a
new year
it feels very helpful back in the Big
Apple Dick Clark's New Year's Rockin Eve
with Ryan Seacrest 2023 is taking over
ABC tomorrow night literally told me
you're like the best part about it that
you never know exactly what's gonna
happen no I I we don't and the weather
changes constantly too throughout the
night and you're prepared you have a
raincoat a puffy jacket I have I have
two pairs of pants one size fits one
size is two sizes too big in case I have
to stuff it with like sweats and long
johns underneath now are you wearing
comfy socks at least I'd wear a couple
pairs of socks and they are comfortable
and those little warmers are in my toes
yeah I am you need them well what's so
cool is you guys are going to be in
Disneyland this year with Sierra uh what
can fans expect the show keeps getting
bigger Billy Porter's coming back Liza
koshy's with me Sierra's going to be at
Disneyland I'm looking forward to it
I'm glad they said Sierra this is the
party you're hosting I was like oh yeah
now you're speaking my language
um but it's awesome it's so beautiful
and then the cool thing is that I will
hit up a couple of rides the next day so
I mean it's just it's perfect around
here
you know I didn't even tell the kids
where I was because there would be
problems in my house
ET was there as they pre-take the Epic
celebration that also kicks off Disney's
100th anniversary some of the headliners
include Shaggy Ali and AJ we watched
this growing up and it's been so special
to be a part of it tonight's been really
magical and Halle Bailey who had her own
fangirl moment over Sierra
it's amazing I'm a huge fan of Sierra I
always have been both from Atlanta the
fact that you know she was introducing
me tonight and seeing her do that that
just made me like well up a little bit
inside because I'm a huge fan of hers
Hallie's other pinched me moment playing
Ariel in Disney's live-action movie The
Little Mermaid
part of that world
it's crazy to think that you know we
filmed it like a year and a half almost
two years ago now you know I look at
even the teaser trailer and I'm like I
feel like that's a whole different
person I've lived a whole other life now
a year and a half has gone by I'm like
wow so it's amazing to finally be able
to see it come out
over on NBC Miley Cyrus returns to host
alongside her godmother Dolly Parton
Miley's New Year's Eve party is about
getting glamorous and dressing your best
well we do that every day don't we Molly
you taught me well you two are quite the
dynamic duo so what can we expect from
you and Miley on New Year's Eve we don't
even know ourselves yet I know we're
going to be doing some skits I know that
Anything Can Happen live with the two of
us I'm sure we'll be wearing some
bizarre costumes and we'll be uh singing
some serious songs some fun songs we'll
be bringing in the New Year in fine
fashion I'm sure it's going to be
legendary she would know I thought me
and Dolly Parton were the perfect pair
to host my New Year's Eve party when she
first asked me I thought it was might be
from New York and I wasn't gonna do it
because I didn't want to get that cold
you know she said no that's why I don't
do it in New York that's why I'm going
to Miami watch me rap on me in the
Florida heat cause I'm
Miley hosted her first New Year's party
last year alongside Pete Davidson it was
NBC's highest rated New Year show in
seven years this year Miley and Dolly
will be performing of course alongside
other special guests like Lotto
boss like me and Sia
[Music]
pool parties harder on New Year's Eve
you or Miley I would think that Molly
probably celebrates a little harder than
me you know I'm not really a party doll
I just look like one and what about
foxes plans well they'll have a
different kind of fireworks show
for the second year in a row Fox won't
be airing a New Year's Eve special the
Omicron surge canceled last year's show
really is he serious enough to know
instead they'll be showing reruns of
Hell's Kitchen pathetic
and for those wanting to celebrate in
their VR space Shaquille's got your back
with the shaqtacular spectacular
this is a new way to ring in the New
Year how did you get involved in this
look I've been doing VR ever since they
first started it way back in the day and
I just told my people I said we need to
do something for new year so we put this
together the immersive special will be
available across mediquest Facebook
Instagram and Messengers watch together
and features an All-Star lineup
cardi B
Ludacris and Rob Gronkowski is my guy
did I did I see Rob Gronkowski twerk
twerking
[Applause]
[Music]
does Shaquille O'Neal do New Year's
resolutions I don't have New Year's
resolution I just tried to
be more at peace
become more happier I gotta call you out
because you do have a New Year's
resolution
and we can look at you and see that
you've lost a lot of weight yes I love
40 pounds I need to lose about 20 more
but how did you lose
well a couple things oh my God my chef
and it's all about eating right I don't
even know what the difference between a
carb and a protein at 50 years old and
once I just started changing those
certain things the weight just fell off
I got eliminate bread and soda so if I
could eliminate bread and soda I think I
can get the monkey wall Burger I want to
be known as the Black Box
I really want to go I wish I knew
something well you can enter
you knew I don't know
foreign
[Music]
that is greatness Dionne Warwick proving
she still got it at 82 years young at
last month's Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade and the legendary singer here
with us right now and how are you
feeling I couldn't be better I really am
feeling so good these days the legendary
singer is as busy as ever she just
wrapped up a Christmas tour she has a
gospel album releasing early next year
and a documentary about her life Dionne
Warwick Don't Make Me Over Premiere
Sunday on CNN
finally people don't get to know me and
know me through me we also hear from
some of your friends some of the people
you're close to Olivia Newton-John who
was a good friend
and this is so terribly Gloria Estefan
yes
Snoop Dogg Doggy Dog and Dr Dre
Dion's actually the one who gave Snoop a
verbal spanking telling him to clean up
his lyrics and treat the ladies right so
here's these words that you're saying
about them is that nice I said you know
your ears and you are going to grow up
you might have a little girl and one day
that little girl's gonna look at you and
say Daddy
did you really say that you know and you
gave them food for thought and uh Snoop
has subsequently thanked me he said I
remember what you said and all of it
came true and I do have a daughter thank
you so much for being here as always we
love having this woman in our presence
we attack my family it's going to be the
last thing you ever do
Harrison Ford and Helen Mirren have
officially added their star power to the
Yellowstone Universe a new episode of
1923 airs this Sunday in our Cassie
Delora caught up with TV's new founding
family
what is your favorite part of your
wardrobe for your character oh I suppose
my hat
I was telling Taylor tonight
that after
20 different hats you know auditioned
for the park he didn't like any of them
that one's too tall that one's too big
that one's too small and then you got
the perfect
yeah but he only found out tonight that
that's a hat I came with that's my hat
in the Yellowstone prequel Taylor
Sheridan introduces fans to a new
generation of the Dutton family who's
faced with plenty of drama how would you
describe the marriage between Cara and
Jacob Dutton he is the leader of the
family I may be the boss but he's the
leader you know but it's a partnership
and it's an equal partnership a
partnership with love Cara supplies a
great deal of uh Jacob's strength
because behind every good man is an even
better woman right
I couldn't have said it better I do have
a great wife as well men kill quick with
a bullet or a noose with their fight is
with me I found working with Helen to be
extraordinarily uh easy simple
straightforward
there's no
fussiness about her
some 1923 fans are also ready to see the
80 year old throw down in his fifth
final Adventure India Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny in theaters June
30th
they did not need to digitally de-age
you my friend but they did what was your
reaction when you first saw that this is
the actual archival footage of me at
that age it's pretty remarkable I blew
me away
it's the mileage
Harrison isn't the only one to watch out
for Sunday night Yellowstone's
mid-season finale is also going down on
the Paramount Network signing this order
is a declaration of war
[Music]
we're already at War there's a lot of
colors within the Dutton family there
are a lot of you know issues within
internally it's full of drama and
struggle enough of that
for the first time
in his life he's got no plan it's just
boiling anger
Taylor give
your guards to your
S I think he
I know he knows how this whole thing
ends because he told me that but I have
no idea what that is aside from seeing
Kevin Costner's character trying to
protect his land as Governor there are
three things fans can expect from the
rest of season five the first one big
happy family and hooker
unfiltered one-liners from our favorite
foul-mouthed Dutton daughter she is in a
very reactionary kind of place and she's
fighting she's just constantly fighting
there are plenty of moments where I
think I can't believe she's gonna do
this but it makes it makes sense she's
got people to fight she's got bad guys
to get you know she's going to stay with
ranch for her dad
we'd also bet money that Wes Bentley's
character Jamie betrays the Dutton
family once again what type of fan
reactions are you getting these days are
people feeling a little sympathetic for
for your character people are torn on
Jamie but often torn within themselves
you know they both hate them and they
love him yeah to the point where people
yell out at grocery stores that they
hate me but they're smiling I mean
they're laughing yeah
first arrived on set on Yellowstone was
one of the most amazing magical days of
my life out of like literally out of the
fog comes Taylor Sheridan on Horseback
and he basically says you ride right and
I was like yeah and he said all right
take that group of cattle and bring them
into the pen and he was like roll
cameras and it was like there was no
rehearsal it was a test frankly I can
tell you it's there's nothing like
getting to go do it
[Music]
foreign